[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's dangerous to go out alone in the
world of the Legend of Zelda breadth of
the wild the unwary can perish in a
matter of seconds
that's why we've compiled nine beginners
tips to help you overcome the games
early threats if you enjoy this video be
sure to LIKE and subscribe to our
YouTube channel for more features on
breath of the wild to learn more about
the secrets breath of the wild has to
offer check out our in-depth video on
the things the game doesn't tell you
[Music]
running headfirst into battle isn't
always the best way to defeat a pack of
enemies often times it's better to take
a moment to formulate a plan of action
before approaching for example if a book
hablen encampment lies ahead think about
what you can do to eliminate them with
as little trouble as possible you could
snipe their archers from a distance with
your bow and then sneak up to the larger
group and throw a bomb at them to
whittle away their numbers or you could
even propel a large metal box towards
the encampment using the stasis
abilities kinetic force there are plenty
of combat tactics that don't involve
wasting resources that are better than
attempting to brute-force your way to
victory
unlike past Zelda games all of breadth
of the wilds weapons and equipment have
a durability mechanic which causes items
to wear down over time and eventually
break after extensive use in battle as
you acquire more powerful weapons and
equipment be mindful of when you choose
to use them save your higher level
equipment for tougher enemies and bosses
as opposed to wasting them against
weaker foes that could easily perish
against lower-level weapons
don't think you need to engage in every
combat encounter there's no shame in
running away your weapon and equipment
resources are limited so it's always in
your best interest to avoid encounters
if there's no goal in mind the world is
packed with enemies that can easily kill
you in one hit choose your battles
carefully or risk wasting your
hard-earned weapons and equipment
[Music]
shrines offer a nice diversion from
prolonged periods of exploration
completing their puzzling challenges
Nets use spirit orbs which can be used
to purchase useful power-ups that expand
your health or stamina but another bonus
you receive from beating a shrine is the
ability to unlock its location is a fast
travel point it's important to take time
to complete shrines is doing so benefits
not only your health and stamina
capacity but also your ability to
traverse Hyrule quickly and efficiently
[Music]
guardians are deadly six-legged flows
that you should avoid at all costs at
least in the beginning of the game but
if you're going to take on a guardian we
suggest coming to the battle on
horseback equipped with an arsenal bomb
arrows and elemental arrows
be sure to slash at its legs to reduce
its maneuverability and amen it's Center
I with your arrows to inflict high
damage
cooking is an essential part to your
survival that can help you in myriad
ways to cook simply choose a few
ingredients from your inventory and drop
them into a bonfire with a pot on it
depending on the ingredients you choose
you'll get a dish or elixir that offers
you a different status effect for
example cooking a raw bird drumstick and
a blue nightshade together makes a dish
that grants you a low-level stealth
boost for two and a half minutes you can
find out more details about an
ingredients effect on a dish via its
inventory explanation but don't be too
greedy with the ingredient types you
choose as using too many cancels out
their effects and results in dubious
food a dish that only heals one heart
keep in mind that cooking status
affecting foods is restricted to
bonfires with pots on them an open fire
will only roast or slightly cook food
items it's also impossible to cook while
it's raining
an enemy wildung a shield can block your
attacks with ease however heavy weapons
like an axe or a hammer can knock the
shield out of their hands making them
vulnerable to attack
utilize this technique whenever you're
up against multiple enemies with shields
[Music]
if you sneak up directly behind an enemy
a prompt appears that allows you to
deliver a devastating blow to them while
their guard is down this is an
incredibly useful maneuver to perform as
it nearly kills enemies in one blow
regardless of their level of health and
defense
[Music]
don't wear anything metal during a
thunderstorm that's about it seriously
you've been warned if there are any
beginners tips that I missed shout it in
the comments below and for more coverage
on The Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild including our full review be sure
to subscribe to our YouTube channel
thanks for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]